un hallazgo como éste sería una
maravilla para la mayoría de los
pescadores de los eeuu pero aquí en
francia esta red llena de cangrejos
azules no es nada más que una excepción
estos pescadores esperaban recoger un
cubo de valiosas anguilas y es que los
cangrejos azules nativos de la costa
atlántica de los eeuu se están
proliferando en el sur de francia
durante los últimos años destruyendo la
población local de ostras mejillones y
anguilas capturadas tradicionalmente y
consumidas en la zona
antes pescamos de 10 a 15 kilos de
anguilas como estas o algunas veces
hasta 40 a 50 kilos y quiero darle hoy
solo encuentra cuatro anguilas en su red
y muchos más cangrejos azules aunque un
kilo de cangrejo azul vale 76 euros en
eeuu son menos populares aquí en francia
sólo cuestan dos euros por kilogramo con
la participación del presidente francés
emmanuel macrón a la apertura de la
cumbre de la unión internacional para la
conservación de la naturaleza en
marsella activistas ambientales y
pescadores buscarán aprovechar la
ocasión para instar al gobierno francés
a actuar en preservación de sus fuentes
de ingresos no sabremos en qué se
convertirá
en auge en este momento es una fase de
establecer un dominio sobre el hábitat
recomendamos que los pescadores pescan
en masa y saquen a los cangrejos del
hábitat y esto podría ser subsidiado
autoridades regionales y estatales
deberían pagarles para este trabajo que
en realidad es casi una misión de
servicio público a
las hembras de los cangrejos azules
pueden poner hasta 2 millones de huevos
para esta especie que prefiere agua
tibia es probable que se proliferen aún
más con el calentamiento global